what's next for spider-man after no way
home while we don't know that we might
be able to get some hints by looking
back at peter parker's mcu journey from
the beginning here's the entire
spider-man mcu story explained
surprisingly peter parker's first
appearance in the mcu doesn't come in
captain america civil war instead that
honor goes to iron man 2 where tony
stark saves a little kid during the
climax of the film while tony's flying
in to stop ivan vanko from using
weaponized hammer drones to attack the
attendants at the stark expo a young boy
in an iron man mask raises his toy
gauntlet to stop one of the drones
before getting some help fans have long
speculated that the masked child was
actually a young peter parker years
before marvel got the go-ahead from sony
to officially add spider-man to the mcu
after all the stark expo takes place in
queens and peter is a long-time science
geek who wouldn't miss the opportunity
to go to an event like that tom holland
told the huffington post in 2017 that as
far as he and mcu head honcho kevin
feige are concerned that unnamed boy is
definitely peter parker no wonder peter
parker grows up to have so much hero
worship for tony stark in the modern day
mcu by the time spider-man homecoming
hit theaters audiences had seen peter's
uncle ben die on the big screen twice in
two different franchises three times if
we count the new perspective on the
murder portrayed in spider-man 3. so
it's no wonder that the filmmakers of
spider-man homecoming chose to skip over
that particular part of spider-man's
origin story that said there's been
enough hints and references to make it
clear that the mcu version of peter
definitely had an uncle ben that he lost
at some point in spider-man far from
home peter's luggage looks second-hand
and bears the initials bfp the luggage
almost certainly belonged to one
benjamin franklin parker before peter
used it according to spider-man
homecoming writers jonathan goldstein
and john francis staley an earlier draft
of the film would have seen aunt may
explicitly mention her dearly departed
husband with all that we can peg uncle
ben's death at around six months before
the events of captain america civil war
since that film shows peter telling tony
that he's had his powers for six months
peter even indirectly mentions that he
blames himself for uncle ben's so far
mysterious death by saying that
look when you can do the things that i
can
but you don't
and then the bad things happen
they happen because of you
in other words with great power comes
great responsibility
in 2015's ant-man scotland's titular
tiny hero runs afoul of sam wilson the
falcon while sneaking into avengers
headquarters naturally it leads to the
two superheroes battling each other in
the classic marvel style although
neither hero walks away the obvious
victor scott gains the device he's after
and something else that he wasn't
expecting sam wilson's respect at the
end of the film scott's friend luis
tells him that his cousin ignacio met
this crazy fine writer chick who
actually knows falcon and in luis's
summation of the conversation we learned
that sam's been looking for ant-man
while he was looking for one bug-themed
superhero he very nearly finds another
well we got everything nowadays we got a
guy who jumps we got a guy who swings we
got a guy who crawls up the walls you
got to be more specific there are plenty
of superheroes in the marvel universe
who jump and swing around the city but
there's only one wall crawler that
casual fans would be likely to recognize
in conjunction with his appearance in
captain america civil war we can infer
that spidey started operating as an
official local superhero during the
events of ant-man even if the bigger
media outlets hadn't yet noticed him
six months after peter gets his powers
tony drops by aunt may's apartment to
meet the mysterious arachnid-themed
superhero who's been showing up on
youtube iron man adds him to his team of
avenger hunting avengers as part of his
ongoing effort to take down bucky so
peter heads to berlin does some
sightseeing and annoys tony stark's
bodyguard and pal happy hogan then he
gets a costume upgrade courtesy of tony
stark and fights against captain
america's team spider-man equips himself
nicely in the fight briefly trapping
falcon and the winter soldier and even
helping iron man and war machine take
down a giant ant-man however the fight
ends with tony's best friend rhodey
wounded by friendly fire as for peter he
suffers a pretty frightening fall
although he ultimately emerges unscathed
after the events of captain america
civil war peter heads back to queens
with his new more technologically
advanced spider suit tony tells peter
that the avengers will let him know if
there are any future missions and in the
meantime he should go to school and
focus on being a local hero two months
later while swinging around on his
after-school crime fighting rounds he
accidentally interrupts an atm heist
organized by crooks who are using
high-tech weapons after a phone call
report with happy goes ignored peter
follows up on the weapons dealers and
gets into a fight with their leader the
vulture tony sends a drone to bail peter
out and give him yet another talking to
about how peter should stop trying to
fight super villains peter half listens
mostly to the parts about how his suit
has a ton of capabilities that he didn't
know about and gets his buddy ned to
hack the suit and give him full access
round two at the vulture in washington
dc ends with peter trapped in a
warehouse for the night and when he
heads off around three on a ferry ride
in new york it turns out that iron man
and the fbi had organized a sting
operation that peter inadvertently
interrupts disappointed in his protege
tony takes back the suit and peter
recommits to his regular life and asks
his crush liz to prom unfortunately
liz's dad is the vulture forcing peter
to take him down in his original low
tech suit before the winged villain can
steal a ton of valuable stark tech
spider-man succeeds vulture goes to
prison liz moves to oregon with her mom
and tony offers peter a place on the
avengers roster if he wants instead
peter turns him down choosing to focus
on being a friendly neighborhood
spider-man for a while
peter's decision to stay close to the
ground and look out for the little guy
lasts about as long as it takes to watch
the credits for spider-man homecoming
when thanos's black order invade earth
in search of the infinity stones in
avengers infinity war spider-man hops
right in to help in defending earth
doctor strange is kidnapped by the black
orders ebony ma and peter chases after
him hitching a ride on the maw's
spaceship before it flies away
completely tony quickly joins him and
provides spidey with the even more
high-tech super suit last seen at the
end of homecoming spidey and iron man
free doctor strange blast ebony ma out
into space and land on titan thanos's
home planet they're quickly joined by
some of the guardians of the galaxy the
heroes prep to fight thanos who soon
arrives to take doctor strange's time
stone to add to his infinity gauntlet
the heroes put up a valiant effort but
their plan goes right and thanos
teleports to earth after nabbing the
time stone soon after he gets the mind
stone from vision puts it all together
and snaps his fingers causing half of
all life in the universe to fade away
unfortunately peter's 50 50 probability
comes out on the negative side and he
turns to dust in tony's arms on an alien
planet i don't
after thanos kills off half of the
universe the remaining half are left to
mourn their fallen friends and family
unfortunately for peter it doesn't seem
like there are many left to remember him
for the five years between thor killing
thanos in the beginning of avengers end
game and when captain america gets the
gang back together it seems like the
only one left to mourn peter is tony
stark he even keeps a framed picture of
his young protege in the kitchen of his
cabin home luckily for spider-man tony
eventually feels guilty enough to rejoin
the avengers once he's back on the team
the avengers head back in time to steal
the infinity stones before thanos could
destroy them in the present timeline and
reconstruct another infinity gauntlet
and with one snap of hulk's mighty hand
the dusted half of the universe is
restored exactly how they were when they
disappeared thanos from a previous
timeline heads to the present in order
to re-snap everything into oblivion but
every superhero or superhero adjacent
character stands in his way including
spider-man peter joins the fight meets
some of his new superhero peers and then
watches as tony stark gives his life to
dust thanos's crew with a snap of his
own
after all that space alien craziness
it's back to normalcy for everyone's
favorite wall crawler in spider-man far
from home with his schoolmates
recovering from you know being dead for
five years peter joins a class trip to
europe he's looking forward to a
relaxing vacation to decompress from all
of that and maybe confess his burgeoning
romantic feelings for mj instead he's
quickly embroiled in a fight against
multiversal elementals alongside nick
fury maria hill and the superhero from
another universe quentin beck aka
mysterio to make things worse peter's
struggling to live up to iron man's
legacy a job that seems all the more
difficult when he receives a pair of
high-tech sunglasses from tony that give
the young hero control over a ludicrous
amount of information and technology
desperate for a mentor peter gives up
his sunglasses to beck whose magic
powers and big brother attitude seem to
make him a better successor to tony than
peter could ever hope to be
unfortunately beck's running a con on
peter and nick fury he's not magic he's
not from another world and he's
definitely not a superhero peter learns
the truth and eventually defeats
mysterio with the villain seemingly
dying in the final battle spidey returns
to new york having saved the day once
again and everything seems to be going
well until that is jay jonah jameson of
the dailybugle.net
leaks mysterio's dying confession and
reveals to the entire world that
spider-man's name is peter parker
spider-man no way home picks up right
where spider-man far from home leaves
off peter and mj are in the middle of
new york trying to digest that peter's
secret identity has been revealed to the
world peter hopes this will all die down
but he is shocked to see his home
surrounded by the press it's not long
before the department of damage control
arrests him and interrogates mj ned and
ant-may however thanks to ace attorney
matt murdock aka daredevil the charges
are dropped peter even goes back to
school where he's met with a mixed
response peter tells mj and ned that
they just need to ride this out for a
few months until they graduate and all
go to mit together unfortunately the
controversy leads the college and every
other college they apply to to reject
the trio outright this leads to a crazy
plan
peter initially approaches doctor
strange and asks him to go back in time
so he could prevent mysterio from
ruining his friends lives strange offers
a spell instead that would make people
forget that peter parker was spider-man
the spell proceeds but peter can't leave
well enough alone constantly
interrupting strange as he casts the
spell to add a number of exceptions the
spell goes awry but strange seems to
contain it however the spell wasn't
totally contained while trying to talk a
representative from mit into changing
her mind peter is attacked by dr octopus
the villain from spider-man 2 when a
pumpkin bomb appears strange teleports
peter back to his sanctum somehow peter
has started drawing in people from other
multiverses that know his identity
strange sends him to track them down
peter captures electro the villain from
the amazing spider-man 2 as well as the
sandman from spider-man 3. strange
captures the lizard and the tortured
norman osborne accepts peter's help
strange plans to send them back to their
realities but things soon got more
complicated
ant-may convinces peter that the
captured villains need help and he can't
simply send them off to die he succeeds
with doctor octopus but norman osborne
reverts to being the green goblin and
persuades the others to once again
target peter as the villains scatter the
goblin kills ant-may leaving peter a
wreck this is all my fault i can't save
everyone in searching for spider-man ned
uses strange's sling ring and
accidentally finds the andrew garfield
version from the amazing spider-man
trying again ned locates the toby
maguire version from the original
spider-man series the two spider-men
track down holland's peter and give him
a pep talk afterwards the trio of
spider-man draw the villains into a
battle at the statue of liberty in an
effort to cure them once and for all it
almost works out but the green goblin
reappears and destroys the apparatus
that contains strange's botched spell
the multiverse starts cracking open as
peter has to be restrained from killing
the goblet he gets the cure but peter is
left with a terrible decision to save
the world peter has to let doctor
strange cast the spell again this time
with no exceptions peter says goodbye to
ned and mj and vows to track them down
and make them remember him when the time
comes however peter can't do it he sees
mj and ned both make it into mit having
finally learned the importance of
responsibility peter gets his own
apartment and continues his career as
spider-man with an uncertain future
there's one last loose end however eddie
brock rather than joining in on any of
the conflict spends his time on the
mcu's earth at a bar just before the
spell pulls him back into his universe
he leaves a single drop of the venom
symbiote in the mcu reality with the
announcement of another sequel in
development this extra-dimensional
visitor may well become a problem for
holland's spider-man
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
spider-man are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]